the latest cbs news polling reveals that
a clear majority of americans favor a
variety of gun restrictions including
universal background checks a federal
red flag law and a ban on the ar-15
style semi-automatic rifle often used in
mass shootings for more on the poll
results let's bring in cbs news
elections and surveys director anthony
salvato anthony thank you for being here
uh i know a lot of parents are talking
to their kids about these mass shootings
are the kids feeling something as a
result yeah they certainly are tony look
at what parents report their kids are
saying in response to this not just that
they're feeling sad but also words like
scared
nervous about gun violence and let me
show you something else that really
underlines the impact of all of this
parents say that their kids when they go
to school are worried about things we've
seen for years bullying social pressures
but gun violence is now expressed by a
majority and it's kind of comparable to
all these other worries that's the
impact with all of these mass shootings
one after another are american attitudes
with regard to gun policy changing yeah
let me show you this um first people
think uh the majority that the
availability of guns is one reason but
one of many reasons that there is so
much gun violence and then to look at
your question the number who say the gun
law should be more strict has risen in
recent weeks after the buffalo tragedy
at 40 54
and then 60 percent now so that's an
increase but tony let me show you a
little bit about the politics of this
because it's going to be so important
going forward and there's a slide over
here that i think underlines a really
important point when you look at policy
measures you look at things like
background checks like red flag laws
that you mentioned you get bipartisan
support for these things when you look
at measures that pertain more expressly
to
the weapons the guns republicans fall
off in their support and that's where
the two parties really diverged so there
may be a difference here in regulating
the people buying the weapons as opposed
to the existence of the weapons
themselves exactly anthony slavanto
thank you very much